[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur wahl des militär
des jahres schön dass sie wieder mit
dabei sind wir zeichnen ja angehörige
des bundesheeres aus die besonderes
geleistet haben und das in den
kategorien rekrut des jahres
zivilbedienstete des jahres einheit des
jahres und soldat des jahres auch
special awards werden verliehen diesmal
kommen wir zur kategorie zur einheit des
jahres zu beginn sehen sie die
nominierten kandidaten nominiert als
einheit des jahres sind
die hermes logistik schule die unter
enormem zeitdruck dem betrieb von 40
test linien in der wiener stadthalle
sicherstellen muss binnen zehn tagen
werden über 80.000 komitees durchgeführt
das operative lufttransport system 130
von september 20 bis august 21 werden
über 5000 flüge einsatz räume
durchgeführt dabei werden über 7.800
passagiere und rund 330 tonnen fracht
transportiert das sanitätszentrum süd
dass nach der ausrufung des
pflegenotstands im seniorenheim sankt
lorenzen in 18 stunden die pflegeleitung
übernimmt das eingeteilte
sanitätspersonal hat dadurch nicht nur
seine professionalität unter beweis
gestellt sondern auch menschenleben
gerettet
wer nun den begehrten preis erhält das
weiß generalstabschef general robert
brieger und
ich freue mich ihnen die einheit des
jahres bekannt geben zu können
seit ausbruch der pandemie stehen unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten fast rund um
die uhr im einsatz
doch nicht nur im inland heißt es helfen
wo andere nicht mehr können auch im
ausland sind unsere einheiten mehr als
gefragt und das schon seit 61 jahren im
jahr 2003 erfolgte die einführung der c
130 hercules im österreichischen
bundesheer seit nunmehr 18 jahren sorgt
dieses system für stabilität beim
personen- und frachttransport aber auch
bei medizinischen notfällen oder der
evakuierung österreichischer und
europäischer staatsbürger in
krisenregionen
2073 flüge wurden seitdem durchgeführt
58 1894 passagiere und 15.000 637 tonnen
fracht wurden dabei transportiert
besonders gefordert ist das operative
lufttransport system 130 seit ausbruch
der cobit pandemie da zum tagesbetrieb
den ausbildungs vorhaben und den
geplanten luftfahrzeug einsetzen
zusätzliche aufträge durchzuführen sind
allen voran die rückholung von
erkrankten soldatinnen und soldaten aus
den einsatz räumen
erschwerend für die crews wirkt sich
dabei natürlich die einhaltung aller
kogit bestimmungen sowie der erhöhte
planungs und koordinierungsbedarf aus
die zusammenarbeit mit den nationalen
und internationalen zivilen luftfahrt
und flugplatz behörden verlangt dabei
ein höchstmaß an professionalität
und diese ist seit einführung des
operativen lufttransport systems 130
stets gegeben ich freue mich daher
diesem team des österreichischen
bundesheeres den award einheit des
jahres zu übergeben
[Musik]
meine herren kommunen es freut mich
ihnen den award einheit des jahres
überreichen zu dürfen ich gratuliere
die einheit des jahres 20 21 das
operative lufttransport system 130
und das setzt sich aus folgenden
einheiten zusammen von der durchführung
sammer den lufttransport staffel sind
die clowns das heißt die piloten die
vielleicht ingenieurs die load master
dann ist im bereich der flieger technik
das technik kind das sich um die
bereitstellung des luftfahrzeuges
kümmert dann ist der lufttransport
umschlag der soviel passagierabfertigung
amerikaner abfertigung zuständig ist und
dann nicht so gut an jetzt sehr wichtig
das führungs tun unsere planung szene
operativer lufttransport zudem versteht
man das unter dispatch dieser die ganze
vorbereitung und auch begleitung der
einsätze durch
[Musik]
da eine kann ohne den anderen nicht das
ist eine schöne bild das sind gemeinsame
prozesse dort wo ein mädchen sich nicht
mehr dreht steht das über werbung
deswegen sind alle beteiligten hier
extrem wichtig und daher vor den vorhang
zu holen natürlich ist auch für die eine
des jahres die kubi pandemie eine
besondere herausforderung
das muss gerade in kobe zeiten so
herausforderung war dies oft hochdruck
auch an feiertagen an wochenenden das
system zu alarmieren und flug fertig zu
machen und so sieht man daran dass vor
allem die roman das müsse doch wie
wichtig ist sowohl wir ein hoch
technisierter verband ist aber unsere
unserer ohne unsere wertvolle
humanressourcen diesen engagierten
leuten wir sind der form zu schauen ist
nicht glücklich gewesen und eines haben
die letzten monate auch wie zeigt dort
wo im zivilen einfach die kräfte weniger
werden systeme wie oft an runtergefahren
das wort der zeitpunkt wo wir eigentlich
hochgefahren sind natürlich unter
beachtung sämtlicher schutzmaßnahmen
auch wir haben schicht betriebe
eingeführt staffel betriebe wir haben
die uns abgewechselt was die abstände
gehalten räumlich und zeitlich
also von herr abfahren oder runterfahren
keine rede ganz im gegenteil
herzliche gratulation dem sieger dem
team des lufttransports systems 130 in
der nächsten folge kommen wir zum
höhepunkt denn da wird der soldat des
jahres gekürt ich hoffe sie sind wieder
mit dabei
[Musik]